The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AUDIENCE: With the
[INAUDIBLE] ceramic class,
I wish we had got to know the
people before because we were
really friendly when
the camera was off,
and they were kind of silent
when the camera was on.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, probably
if we went back now,
it would be different.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I feel like the
boom was really intimidating
because I'd be like, oh,
like, it's in their faces,
and trying to get in.
You could hear their
voices just drop
and then cut off whatever
they were saying.
So, yeah, I felt uncomfortable
because I came in--
like, Katarina was there for
a while before I came in.
And then, as soon as I got
there, I got my camera.
And the first time I
was talking to people
I was, like, behind it.
So, I don't.
I think I was more reserved
in what I was asking them
and how close I was
getting to them.
So, I think this part is just
getting comfortable with it
and just--
then I think if I had gotten a
chance to talk to some of them,
it would be better.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
the way a camera
changes the situation
is pretty amazing.
And that's obviously
a huge part of what
we've been talking about.
The boom is also a
big part of that.
And as you say, especially for
people who haven't experienced
that before, it can be kind
of intimidating because it's
like this weapon, right?
And the ways around that are,
as we discussed in class,
you can actually attach
the directional microphone
to the top of the camera,
which at least makes
it more of a compact unit.
You do sacrifice some ability
to get really good sound
in certain situations because
you can't get the microphone as
close, obviously,
since it's limited
to wherever the camera is.
But it does have the
advantage that there's
only one intimidating piece of
equipment in the room, not two,
and it's more contained.
So, that is something
that you might consider
for some kinds of situations,
and it may or may not
be appropriate.
And then, of course, the other
thing is, yeah, prepping.
Prepping the room, prepping
the scene, meeting the people.
Again, depending on
how much time you have,
meeting them without a camera
before you take the camera out.
As I think I said before,
I'll often come with a camera,
but I won't necessarily
be committed
to the idea of taking it out
the first time I meet people
because you just have
to see how it goes.
And if it seems really great
and they're very comfortable
and you make a lot
of progress, you
can say, oh, do you mind
if I shoot something?
But if there is that need to
build a rapport before you
get to that point, you just
leave the camera in the bag.
And then, if something
amazing is starting to happen,
you have it.
But I realize also that
in an exercise situation,
you're not necessarily going
to spend a week or two building
a rapport with a ceramics class
before you go out and shoot.
But part of what
we're doing here
is trying to get some experience
in these different kinds
of shooting, and just
get an idea of some
of the challenges involved in
the different kinds of things.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
And one other thing.
We talked about this
a little bit before,
but if you did, say, have
someone with a camera,
as Chris mentioned, with a
unidirectional-- the longer mic
on top, it could still be
helpful to have two people.
Because in that
instance, one person
can be focusing on shooting
it, and the other person
could be focusing on just
interacting with people.
And then that gives people
in the ceramics class
or whatever the situation
is somebody to focus on,
as opposed to focusing on
whoever has the equipment.
So, sometimes that helps people
become a lot more comfortable.
One person can be in charge of
socially engaging with whoever
it is that you're working
with, and the other person
can focus on the
shooting and the sound.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And then,
another thing that you can do,
which we don't really have the
equipment to do in this class.
But if you had, for instance,
a digital audio recorder
of your own, the
other person could
carry the digital audio
recorder and a microphone,
just handheld.
And that's a little less
intimidating, as well.
And you can obviously get closer
or get a different sound angle,
or you can record the
sound separately and then
sync it up in editing.
So, that's yet another
technique that you
could use to get a different
kind of audio perspective
without using the boom
and being as intimidating.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: If
we had more equipment.
CHRIS BOEBEL: The boom is great
for some situations, obviously,
but it does introduce another
element of distraction.
So, the other thing
that I wanted to do
is talk a little bit more about
Errol Morris, just kind of wrap
that up since we were a
little truncated on Wednesday.
And then we're going
to go on to talk
about this current
assignment a bit more.
We're going to get a visit
from a dean, Christopher Jones,
who's going to talk a little
bit about MIT students.
And we're also going to talk
about interview techniques
and various things
to think about when
you're setting up an interview.
So, that's today.
But just first, to
spend a few minutes
thinking about Errol
Morris, or wrapping that up.
Final reactions or thoughts
that people didn't get a chance
to say to his work or to that
final film, The Fog of War?
AUDIENCE: It was interesting
how he actually used
a lot of jump cuts to do it.
It really is different
from normal films.
You would think-- he's
a very famous person.
It's not like it's something
he just put together.
But I think it's interesting to
hear his own voice randomly--
not randomly, but
at different points.
And then you have it just jump
between thing and another.
I think one of the [INAUDIBLE]
he'd fade out and then fade in.
But I think in this one, he
just didn't do that as much.
Or at least [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I liked it because
it was a good example of what
to do with my last piece
because it was really based
on what the person was saying.
And then I would cut.
And so I was having
difficulty because I
didn't want it to sound like
this random voice from nowhere.
And so I kept trying to
go back to the person.
But then, after
looking at it, I was
like, oh, it's so much of her.
I really wanted to show
more of the food, as well.
So, I think watching him, it
was a really good balance.
And there's actually more of
everything else than on him,
but I didn't feel
like I didn't know
who he was when he was talking.
So, I think that
helped, at least,
figure out how to
do some of that.
I'm not exactly sure
how he did it, though.
I think [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BOEBEL: That makes sense.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: I was
going to mention in relation
to Sabrina's comment.
So, the focus on the jump cuts.
So, when we're thinking,
again, the contrast
between digital cinema style--
direct, sorry.
Between direct cinema style
and Errol Morris's style.
Again, the direct cinema
style is much more--
focusing less on the editing.
Obviously, editing
is still part of it,
but less of a focus
on the editing,
and you don't really want
to call attention to it.
And generally you don't
call attention also
to the person who's
doing the filming.
So, in both of those
cases, again, him
breaking very strongly with
direct cinema style where--
doing jump cuts.
Calling attention to the fact
that this is being filmed,
that this is being staged.
Hearing his voice off camera.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
you can think about it
as, in a lot of ways, all
documentary filmmakers in one
way or another are in
conversation with this question
of the artifice of filmmaking.
So, they're taking
something that is reality
and they're trying to represent
it through this medium that
is about artifice
and manipulation
and the direct cinema
approach has just
minimized the sense
in which that there's
a manipulation, whether or
not it's true that there is.
And Errol Morris is saying, I'm
just going to put it out there.
I'm editing.
This is edited here.
This is my interpretation
of what was said,
and I am manipulating
what was said.
And I'm showing you
where I cut things out.
And I'm not going
to worry about it.
The other thing that's
interesting about his work,
for better or worse,
is if you think
back to some of the
very early stuff we saw,
like that film on the
whirlwind computer
from the '50s with the voiceover
narration, the voice of God
narration, in some
ways, his technique
is very similar to that, except
that it's not a voice of God
yet.
The voice is really
located in the subject.
But he, in so many
ways, is illustrating
what's being said with
cutaways, with found footage,
or various kinds of imagery.
But rather than being a literal
illustration, in many cases,
it's more of a psychological
or a very, very surjective
illustration.
And the music, of course,
the Philip Glass music
in that piece really
highlights that
and increases the feeling
of subjective dislocation,
if that's the right term.
AUDIENCE: Would you say there is
much more planning before even
deciding to shoot a
Morris-style kind of film,
whereas with direct
cinema, there is only--
I mean, how much planning should
you do before a direct cinema
experiment?
CHRIS BOEBEL: I think it's hard
to say how you would answer
that because it really depends
on exactly what you're doing.
The planning, in the case
of an Errol Morris film,
is picking the right subject.
Picking someone who
who will hold up
under that kind of intense
scrutiny as a human being,
as a personality, who's
engaging enough to carry a film.
And many of his
films, obviously,
aren't carried by a
single individual.
But all of them are
about people who can
talk in some way or another.
Whether or not they
can talk in the sense
of being very articulate.
And, of course, McNamara is
very articulate in that film.
But some of his
characters are just
very compelling in other ways,
not because they're necessarily
so able to speak.
But they're
compelling characters.
And so, there's a huge
amount of pre-production
in picking the right
people to tell the story,
and picking a story that lends
itself well to that technique.
And then, after that,
it's interesting
because is it
pre-production work
or is it post-production work?
Because there's so
much work and attention
that has to be done to
structuring a story when
you do it like that.
What are the linking bits?
How do you get
people-- and this is
what we'll talk about
later in class-- how
do you get people to tell
their story in a coherent way,
or in a way that can be
made coherent in editing?
So, for instance, if
I'm interviewing Chris
and I want to get
her life history,
and I say, when were you born?
And she says,
1960-whatever it was.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: 65.
CHRIS BOEBEL: 65.
I can't really use that unless
you include my question.
So, I need her to say,
I was born in 1965.
And then, hopefully, to make
some kind of observation
on why that might
even be interesting.
So, that's what
we're going to talk
about in the last half of
class, how you actually
do things like that.
What kinds of basic
techniques can you
use to get people to
talk about themselves.
Or about whatever you're
asking them about.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: I
mean, I think probably,
maybe what Katarina
is trying to get it.
I mean, there is--
we were talking some about how
Errol Morris likes to use sets.
And there is discussion
in some of the readings,
for example, when he was
shooting Fast, Cheap,
and Out of Control that he
did these nighttime shoots
with the topiary.
And he wanted to do
it in slower speed.
So, there's massive,
massive numbers of light.
So, in that sense, yeah.
I mean, a lot of emphasis
for Errol Morris,
depending on what
he's shooting on,
creating sets, and creating
the context for how
he wants things to look.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Because again, he's
not afraid of embracing the
artificial qualities of film.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And thinking
also about in Gates of Heaven
when he created
those portraits--
I mean, obviously, when
he was shooting interviews
with people, he was
spending a lot of time
in the setup
beforehand, what exactly
do I want to have
in the background,
how do I frame this in a
way that's absolutely right.
So, there was a great
deal of emphasis
placed on setting
up those interviews
before he even interviewed them.
So, in that sense, yeah.
I mean, there is a
lot more planning,
whereas the direct cinema
style being more, OK, let's
grab the camera,
let's hop into--
ah, there's people doing stuff.
Let's just hop right in
and follow them along
and do whatever.
So, in that sense--
CHRIS BOEBEL: In direct
cinema, the planning
can involve access.
Think about primary.
I don't know the story,
but it may or may not
have been easy to get
the kind of access
that they needed in order to
follow Humphrey and Kennedy.
Or any kind of film.
I mean, obviously, there's
a lot of negotiation that
has to go on before you
can even be in the room
with people that are
free to be themselves,
and that would allow
you to actually capture
something direct cinema style.
So, it can vary.
But yeah, I mean,
certainly in terms
of the experience
of filming, one
is about spontaneity and being--
well, they both can
be about spontaneity.
But one is about being
freewheeling and not
trying to direct, and
embrace this artifice,
the plastic elements of
film that we talked about
at the beginning.
And the other is very much
like, well, that's what film is.
Why not?
So, at 11:00,
we're going to have
a visit from Dean
Christopher Jones, who's
going to talk a little
bit about MIT students.
And just to prep
for that, I wanted
to talk a bit about the
second part of the assignment.
As I said, I'm encouraging
you for the second part
of this exercise, which is
an interview-based exercise,
I'm encouraging your teams
to interview an MIT student.
And this may become part of a
project that I'm working on,
which is essentially a profile
of the MIT student body, which
is going to be shown
in various events
as part of the MIT
150 celebration that's
happening right now.
Including possibly before
this big convocation
that's happening at the Boston
Convention Center in April.
So, it's kind of fun.
It could be kind of cool.
And what I'm interested
in is the idea
of how MIT students
look at MIT students.
Both graduate and
undergraduate, no distinction.
Although, obviously,
there is a difference.
And I'm just kind of
interested in the question of,
is there a typical MIT student?
Are there characteristics
that cross
traditional boundaries of
ethnicity, or gender, or age,
or interest?
It's a truism to say that
MIT students are just
an incredibly
diverse lot when it
comes to their interests
and their goals
and their aims in life.
And I'm just interested
in seeing what
MIT students think about that.
So, I would strongly
encourage you,
if you're at all interested,
to participate in that.
And Dean Jones is going to talk
a little bit about strategies
for that, as well.
And I'm also-- the
second part of this
is, I would very much love
to have the opportunity
to film you filming.
So, if you're able to do
this and you actually want
to profile an MIT student--
again, grad or undergrad-- and
it's very open as to who you
might choose, I would love to
be able to come and spend a very
short amount of time--
not the entire time
because we know
how cameras can influence
those kinds of things.
But I would love to come capture
just a little bit of actually
doing the exercise.
We can talk about this
offline or separately.
But over the next week, I would
love to try to, if possible,
coordinate schedules to do that.
So, also in advance
of the exercise,
I wanted to show you a film
that was made here at MIT,
or show you a few minutes of
a film that was made in 1957--
maybe some of you have seen
it, although probably not--
called The Social Beaver.
Anybody heard of this film?
Which is a very
interesting example of how
MIT views itself, or not.
You'll recognize some
of the techniques
that we've discussed in
class, like especially
in the first part of class.
But I'm just going to show the
first seven or eight minutes,
and then we can talk
a little bit about it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The Charles River in
Massachusetts separates Boston
from the famous University
City of Cambridge.
Here, stretching for a
mile along the north bank,
is the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
known the world over as MIT.
This famous university
offers to its students
intellectual challenge
together with fellowship.
MIT, founded in 1861 by William
Barton Rogers, a distinguished
natural scientist,
has, for a century,
been the leader
in the development
of science and technology.
Today, devoted to
the highest goals
of education and research,
MIT is a new type
of educational institution.
A modern University built around
science and technology rather
than classical
studies, but embracing
the arts, the social
sciences, and the humanities.
The campus contains 100 acres.
The main educational
group of buildings,
centered around
the Great Court, is
a single, continuous
structure, although it
is divided into numbered
sections referred
to as buildings.
MIT's campus is
all inclusive with
an extensive athletic plant
and playing fields fully
accessible.
So are the
recreational buildings,
dormitories, and dining halls.
It is a pleasant place in
which to work and live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The dormitory system permits
students of all classes
to live in any of the
undergraduate houses.
The Dorrance Laboratory houses
food technology and biology,
and is the leader in biophysical
and biochemical research.
The swimming pool and squash
courts occupy this building.
The Institute provides
this beautiful home
for its presidents.
Walker Memorial houses a
large student dining hall
and is the student
activities center.
The Charles Haden
Memorial Library
is the center of the
Institute library system.
The facilities for
study at MIT are fine,
but these able and
vigorous students
need many extracurricular
activities
to complete their development
for future communal, family,
and social relationships.
Symbolized by the mascot beaver,
engineer of the animal world,
the active student after classes
is indeed the social beaver,
for MIT offers him
complete fulfillment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A large student leaving group
resides in the dormitories
and enjoys a type
of community living.
Roommates work
together harmoniously.
Apartments are provided in
each dormitory for a faculty
resident and his wife, who
live among the students
and open their apartments
to them for evening bull
sessions, snacks, and
general sociability.
Numerous lounges are
available to the students.
Dormitory living provides
unlimited opportunities
for working and
playing together.
Throughout the
Institute's living groups,
emphasis is placed
on the individual.
Yet each student is exposed
to many different philosophies
and ideas.
Chess is popular.
There are rooms for ping
pong, billiards, cards, music,
and photography.
Dorm parties are unique.
This is driftwood drag.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Dormitory council governs
the dormitory system.
Each house has its own
committee to plan dances,
student-faculty coffee
hours, and intramural sports.
MIT has over 25 local and
national fraternities,
each with its own house.
In this leaving group,
informal bull sessions
are always taking place,
with the talk ranging
from nuclear fission to girls.
Each house must,
of necessity, offer
the atmosphere and conditions
conducive to study.
Each fraternity member is
provided with a quiet study
area, an adequate
desk, and, of course,
the inevitable hi-fi
set is close by.
Mutual aid in studies is
sought and cheerfully given.
Every fraternity has a
full slate of officers
and holds periodic
meetings of its members.
Each house conducts its
affairs in businesslike manner.
Before the freshman
quizzes, it is
customary in most
houses for upperclassmen
to give formal review sessions.
About 100 coeds attend MIT
and participate in all aspects
of student affairs.
The girls have their
own social rooms
in the main school building.
Inside this door, it's
strictly no men allowed.
Here the coeds congregate
between classes
and relax from the
pressure of class work.
Among other things, this is the
girls' communication center.
In typical feminine
fashion, the girls
take time out to gossip about
clothes and dates exchange news
and congratulate or
sympathize with one another
about their grades.
MIT coeds are gifted
musically, too, and relax
in this enjoyable
manner after finishing
with gossiping and other talk.
When studying in
the horizontal, one
must be prepared to
accept this consequence.
The Margaret Cheney
room is actually
a beautifully appointed
suite of rooms.
Besides the large
living room, there
is a locker room,
fully equipped kitchen,
and this special study room.
Here the girls study
in complete silence,
and the signs of intense
concentration are evident.
Well, most of the time anyway.
After all, the studios beaver
is also the social beaver.
And what is more natural
than planning and daydreaming
about that new evening gown?
The women's dormitory
at 120 Bay State Road
is comfortable and homelike.
Here the girls share
in the work and play
that is typical of
girls' dorms everywhere.
On a weekend, the living room
is likely to look like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS BOEBEL: So.
Anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
So, that's how MIT
represented itself in 1957.
Thoughts?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: She doesn't.
Need some space to go
relax from the pressure?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: It was interesting
because they didn't show
a lot of the building inside.
They showed the outside, which
made it look really beautiful.
Whereas MIT ranks, in the past,
number one sore eye school.
So, yeah, the fact
that they want
it to look really beautiful
and really ideal, and--
CHRIS BOEBEL: On a
nice spring day when
all the flowers are blooming.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Like, when has
that ever happened?
AUDIENCE: People aren't
really [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, maybe they
weren't there then,
but there's a lot
of [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: It was weird.
Also, when they
cut between places,
you knew where some
of the plants were,
but they weren't
all near each other.
And so they cut to [INAUDIBLE]
and then [INAUDIBLE]
go back and forth, and they
show different things engraved,
I guess, in the buildings.
But it was all not near
each other, per se.
So, if you didn't
know where it was,
it was kind of weird when
you kind of know where it is.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What was it shot?
CHRIS BOEBEL: It
came out in 1957.
So I assume it was shot around
that time or right before,
yeah.
It was produced by an alum
from the class of 1922.
So, he was already in his
late 50s when he made this.
That's an interesting question.
Would the students of that time
have thought about this film?
I mean, it was obviously
pretty typical in terms
of its technique and
its style for the time.
So it's not that
it would have been
seen as so outrageous the
way we might look at it,
but I would have been curious
to know what the current student
body would have
thought about it.
AUDIENCE: Well, basically,
it doesn't really
say anything about the social
life of students at MIT.
It's a promotional media about
how great MIT students are.
But do we see any
evidence of this?
No.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I mean, and it's--
yeah.
I mean, it's obviously
this voice of God narration
that we talked about at
the beginning of class,
and then everything
is illustrated.
But even the things that
they choose to focus on are--
it's all infrastructure.
The women's dorm is
at 120 Bay State Road.
Here's the special lounge.
Here's this building,
here's this building,
here's this building.
So, yeah.
It's very interesting that
the social life of the student
is kind of all communicated
via infrastructure.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
But then, I think--
I mean, the same way that
MIT does now, I mean,
so much of this
is intended to try
to counter other stereotypes
about science and engineering
students to be
completely asocial.
I mean, that's the whole point.
And so deliberately
showing shots of--
I mean, most of the shots,
the students being social.
But it's also a lot of
young men and young women
together, I mean,
with the intent
of deliberately trying to
counter other stereotypes that
would have--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
just the fact that--
I mean, as retro
and obviously sexist
as that portrayal
is, just the fact
that there's so much emphasis on
the fact that women attend MIT.
Because--
AUDIENCE: Yes, but how
many women [INAUDIBLE]??
CHRIS BOEBEL: Only 100.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, only 100.
CHRIS BOEBEL: But they were
proud of the fact at that point
that there are 100 because if
you go back five or six years
before there were like, 17.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
And before that, it
was really MIT was
the men's school here,
and its "partner school,"
quote unquote, was Wellesley.
That's why there's still
this ongoing connection
with Wellesley.
So, that was the idea, was
that the MIT students would--
so social events there were
between Wellesley and MIT.
AUDIENCE: I wonder if
they were trying to--
because they show the girls
doing some more silly stuff
than the guys doing.
But you wonder how much of that
was trying to say, oh, look,
they're normal, or
trying to [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS BOEBEL: I think
they were trying to say
they're normal, yeah, I agree.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
But, as you say,
I mean, the language and
the first thing that they
say coming into--
oh, here's the space
where the young women go
to relax from the pressure.
I mean, that's not
what they say when
they introduce the young
guys going into their dorms.
I mean, it is pretty--
AUDIENCE: Fall
asleep and crying.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, they gossip.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] while
the guys study together.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: That, yeah.
AUDIENCE: They
never even mentioned
any type of study they did
at all, whereas the guys were
like, oh look, they're studying
engineering and [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean, they're walking
a fine line here because I'm
sure they're very aware that a
lot of the audience is going,
why would women
go to MIT at all?
What are they doing studying
engineering and science?
My goodness, that seems wrong.
So they're trying to make
it like, oh, but there's
this friendly, home-like
environment where
they live, and they have this
special lounge where they
can relax from the pressure.
But at the same
time, they're also
aware that another
segment of their audience
is saying, even
at that time, it's
outrageous that only
100 women attend MIT.
And so they're trying
to be very political,
and not succeeding very well.
AUDIENCE: So when
did the walker--
I mean, when did the
student activity center
move to the ugly building?
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS BOEBEL: I don't know.
Where was that built?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, one of
the new student [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know.
Don't know.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I don't know.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But
I mean, one question--
I mean, I'm not
sure exactly if this
was one of the directions
you wanted to go,
but thinking about
how diversity at MIT
would have been
presented at this time
and how it would be
conceptualized now.
I mean, so here, obviously,
the only diversity here is,
OK, there are women here.
And it is completely presented
in a heterosexually oriented
kind of frame where that's the
assumption, that this is, OK,
we've got women here so
you guys can hook up,
kind of is the assumption
built into there.
And there's not
discussion in terms
of other kinds of diversity.
There's not discussion in
terms of class diversity,
ethnic and racial
diversity, sexual diversity.
I mean, so there's a very--
how would diversity on
campus been conceptualized
at that point in
terms of how would it
be conceptualized now in terms
of how people think about,
well, what entails a
diverse student body?
And what would be considered
to be the ideal composition
of the MIT student body?
AUDIENCE: They do mention class
diversity, so in the dorm,
students of all
classes [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
But I thought-- see,
I did the first thing, too.
I thought they were
talking about social class,
but I think they
meant of all classes,
like freshman, sophomore,
junior, senior.
It wasn't about social classes.
It was--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Harvard, [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY: No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, there there
was that feeling at the time.
I think Chris is
right that that's
what they were talking about.
But MIT, particularly at
that time, but continuing,
has always seen itself as
an institution in comparison
to, say, the Ivy Leagues where
social class matters, does not
matter, and where
it's a meritocracy.
That's the self-perception.
And it doesn't necessarily
inform this film.
I think that, as Chris said,
that what's informing this film
is this need, number one, to
show off the infrastructure,
which is really interesting.
And number two, to counter
stereotypes of MIT students
as people who have no social
lives, study all the time.
This whole issue that
I mentioned of the fact
that they want to
brag about the fact
that there are women
there, women at MIT.
But they're also worried
about alumni who are probably,
at that time, outraged
that they've now
let in over 100 women.
So, that is the overriding
purpose of the film.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it doesn't--
it shows social life as
in student activities,
but it doesn't really
show social life
as people that are working.
So students that are in the
lab, or taking lunch break,
or even talking as they are.
I just wonder what kind of
choices were finally made.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, again--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: There there
are two things going on here.
Both are very interesting, and
both relate to this exercise
that we're talking about.
I mean, one is the
stylistic choices.
And that is partly just
a product of the time.
So, the way of making a
documentary at that point
is basically thinking
of it as a newsreel.
Write a script that says what
you want to say, and then
illustrate the script.
Go out with a
camera and a tripod
and frame up a bunch of shots
that you have on a list,
and then write it to the script.
So, there isn't necessarily
a sense of spontaneity
or these kinds of issues that
we've been talking about,
how you get at other
kinds of things,
either via interviews or via
cinema verite, direct cinema
kinds of approaches.
So that's one thing.
But then, yeah,
the other thing is,
how do you represent
yourself, and how do you
get at the reality of what a
particular group of people is?
I mean, genre and
style aside, it's
very, very easy to make the
equivalent of this film now.
It's just that it wouldn't look
like that or sound like that.
And one of the things that
I'm interested in doing
is trying to get you guys to
participate a little bit so
that this is not
quite like that.
And, obviously,
what we make now is
more palatable to 21st
century eyes and ears.
But there's still this whole
question of representation--
"top-down representation,"
quote unquote--
or people who
represent themselves.
I mean, it's like
Indigenous media.
[CHUCKLES]
Well, we've been having
a great conversation
about diversity and the
MIT educational experience.
Diversity in its many forms.
And it's been
really interesting.
So, you can kind of--
CHRISTOPHER JONES: I'm
ready to be educated.
CHRIS BOEBEL: You could
give your perspective,
and then, yeah, just
continue the conversation
we've been having.
But for those of you who
don't know Christopher,
he's the assistant dean
for graduate students.
Here's a graduate
degree from MIT
himself, and has been
involved for a long time
in a number of programs, such
as the MIT Summer Research
Program, MSRP.
The Amgen Scholars Program.
I know I'm missing a ton.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: That's OK.
CHRIS BOEBEL: But he
spends a great deal
of time thinking about the
makeup of the graduate student
body here and actively
working to recruit students.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Yes.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So, I thought it
would be a great thing for him
to come in and talk a little bit
about some of the stuff we've
just been talking about.
And just to give you a recap,
we talked about the assignment.
And then we watched
eight minutes
of a film that was made
in the '50s here on MIT
students, which is quite funny.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: I bet it was.
CHRIS BOEBEL: If
you can imagine.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTOPHER JONES: On
many levels, right?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Exactly, yeah.
And we were just having a
really interesting conversation
about, as I said, diversity.
Not just the traditional
measures of diversity, but also
academic diversity.
So, if you want to speak for
a couple of minutes, and then
we can continue
the conversation.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Sure.
Yeah, I'd love to.
I think the richness of it is
going to be the conversation.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Would
you prefer to stand,
or would you like a chair?
CHRISTOPHER JONES: I
don't know, what's better?
What do you all usually do?
What do you want?
I can stand, I can sit.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Whatever you want to do.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
whatever you prefer.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: I'll
stand up for a little bit
since I've been sitting all day.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
I'll keep this over here
in case you change your mind.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Cool, cool.
I've actually been
sitting all night, too.
You have to excuse me.
So, I don't if you
mentioned, but I'm
also in a PhD program
here, in addition
to being assistant dean.
And I have a problem
set due today.
And I took a nap at
3 o'clock, and then
got back up to work on it.
So, I apologize if I'm
a little bit off today.
But it's good to see you all.
Thank you for inviting me.
When I heard about the
project, I was really excited
for a number of reasons.
One, because I think
it's always great,
one of the wonderful
things about MIT
is its ability to get out of
the way of student innovation.
So, to really move
out of the way
and help to facilitate
student innovation.
And I think this is
an example of that.
I think we really
believe in the strength
and the power of the students.
So, I wanted to say
a couple of things,
and then I'd really want
to hear more about all
and engage in a
dialogue, if that's OK.
And I think the
things that I'll say
are centered around a
question that Chris asked me
a while ago, and that was,
what is a typical MIT student?
I don't if you've had
that conversation.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I raised
that as a question,
but have not really talked--
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Any answers?
CHRIS BOEBEL: We
didn't get there yet.
CHRISTOPHER JONES:
You didn't get there?
Anyone want to
throw out anything?
Do you believe there is
a typical MIT student?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I was trying to think of
how I would describe it,
and I can't really put a gender
on it, or a race, or a class.
Primarily, they're a science
or engineering student that--
CHRISTOPHER JONES: But
not exclusively, right?
AUDIENCE: What?
CHRISTOPHER JONES: But
not exclusively, right?
AUDIENCE: Not exclusively.
And having a diverse
set of interests.
A little eccentric.
Intuitive.
Mostly their personality
traits [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Yeah.
So, I think I think one of
your challenges is going to be,
in the midst of such diversity--
we're from all over the world,
at least at the graduate level.
At the undergraduate
level, there
are about 8% international
student, 8% or 9%
international students.
At the graduate level, about
40% international students.
So there are a lot of people
from a lot of different places
here.
And we have all sorts of
interests and background.
People that love jousting.
People that love baking.
People that love
ballroom dancing.
People that love sitting and
watching sitcoms all day long.
After they finish their
homework, of course.
So, we have a huge
range of interests.
And I think part of your
challenge is going to be,
in the midst of all
of that, is there
a common thread
that ties what seems
to be very different
individuals together?
And I think, for me
at least, thinking
about this particular project,
if there's a way for you all
to pull out the common
thread while not negating
or missing the
individuality, then
I think that will enhance
the work that you do.
So, to get back to the
question, and Chris
and I have talked about
it a little bit before,
I think there are some--
I think MIT students
are very different.
However, there is a least common
denominator, if you would.
Because I get the question
all the time, part of my job
is to go out and
recruit students
to MIT at the graduate level.
And so everyone's asking, well,
what's an MIT student like?
Is there a typical MIT student?
What's the experience
like at MIT?
What do people do there?
What makes someone special?
I do think there is an X factor.
I think there's a secret sauce.
And to me, the secret
sauce is in the least
common denominator, and it's
made up of a few things.
One, and it kind of captures
what you were saying,
but one is this
unapologetic passion.
Most people at MIT are just
passionate about something.
Now, you may not care about
what they're passionate about.
You may have never heard of
You may not necessarily
agree with it.
But I think if you
walk around the campus,
you'll notice that
people are really, really
passionate about something.
Never in my life had
I been to any campus
and I'd see somebody walking
around in a purple flight suit.
But you get to MIT,
and after a while
you see somebody
walking around or riding
on a unicycle in a purple
flight suit while juggling,
and you just walk
by like it's normal.
That person is passionate about
unicycles, purple fly suits,
and juggling.
And guarantee that
everyone in this room
is passionate about something.
I think the other thing is
this idea of an immense drive.
And you see it--
you really, really see
it in the students.
And I'm sure--
I know one of you all.
I don't know the
rest of you all.
But if you all are like
the one that I do know,
then I know you all
have an immense drive.
Meaning despite the
challenges that come up,
whether it's academic,
cultural, social,
you really drive
towards those things
that you're passionate
about, and you're
willing to overcome
the barriers.
MIT students are
involved in going
to Haiti, in the turmoil
in the Middle East now.
Real world problems.
While at the same
time being involved
in coming up with new
programs for our new systems
to allow computers to
interact with humans.
You name it.
So, there's this drive to
create and to learn and to do.
And I think there
is one other factor.
And again, I'm
forgetting it, and I
don't remember what it is.
But it'll come out
in the conversation.
So, I say that to
say, I personally
believe that there are
some common elements
among MIT students.
And I would love--
because I really want to see
the work that comes out of this,
and I would love
to see how you all
manage to, while highlighting
the individuality,
manage to find that common
thread amongst students at MIT.
I think the other
thing I'll say,
and then I would love to hear
what you all were talking about
and to get some dialogue,
is I wanted to underscore
the significance and importance
of the work that you're doing.
We go about our life without
thinking about our life often.
We go about our life
without thinking
about the relationships
that we have.
And one of the most important
components of our life
is relationships.
And the more we understand and
can appreciate the differences
of individuals-- because
it's easy to find somebody
that you're common with, right?
So, I can walk
around down the hall,
and if I see a Black
male that has a suit on,
that's an easy connection.
Hey, how's it going?
That's an easy connection.
The more difficult
connection is with someone
that doesn't look like me,
that doesn't act like me.
And if I can find a way
to make that connection--
or doesn't think the
same way that I do--
then what ultimately happens
is it enhances who I am.
And I think if you
all, in this project,
what I would love
to see out of it
is how you went about getting
outside of your own comfort
zone, finding a way to
connect with someone that's
really different from you.
Because in the
process of doing that,
I think we as MIT could learn
how to actually do that.
And that's something
that we need to learn.
Not just MIT, but
other places, too.
One of the things that--
and I'll end with this--
as an undergraduate
student, I worked at NASA.
And my advisor was
Franklin Chang-Diaz.
He's an astronaut.
And when I graduated--
I think I may have mentioned
this to you before.
When I graduated, I
was admitted into MIT
and had to go back to NASA
to work for that summer.
And at the end of the summer,
I gave a presentation.
And we talked, and we
were talking about MIT.
And one of the things that
he said to me that I'll never
forget was, when you go to
MIT, don't lose your humanity.
I didn't quite understand
what he was talking about.
But having been
here for a while,
I see that, in the
midst of our deep drive
and in the midst of our
endless pursuit of excellence,
it's easy to lose our humanity.
That human connection.
I think we've done
a really good job
in the last decade
of making sure
that students and
faculty and staff
have that human connection.
And I would love to
see this project add
to what is being done to
help us really understand
how to maintain a
human connection,
because that's most important.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And I'll
just add one other thing.
One of the reasons that
we watched the film
that we watched, or
the selection from it,
is that another way that
I could have approached
making this film would have been
to essentially cast students
myself and go interview them.
And I was somewhat resistant
to do that because I was afraid
that it would end up being like
a more contemporary version
of that, which is a top-down
look at the student body
and what MIT students are
like and what they do.
And so this is kind
of an experiment,
and I'm hoping that
you'll participate
by looking at each other,
looking at yourselves.
So, we'll see what happens.
But anyway.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Do you
all have any major concerns
about the project?
Good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's not
really a concern.
I'm just wondering
because I'm just
speaking-- you were
talking about [INAUDIBLE]
but at the same
time, [INAUDIBLE]..
So, after watching this
video, [INAUDIBLE]??
If you were a woman, you would
be happy [INAUDIBLE] discussion
around that.
But then, the way we look
at it now, [INAUDIBLE]??
So now, we're talking about
the issues that [INAUDIBLE]..
Are we going to touch on
those issues [INAUDIBLE]
few years from now, and
then perhaps watching
the video that was
made from this time,
they will be like,
oh, [INAUDIBLE]..
My first impression was
like, wow, that's great.
It's only been 50 years or
60 years and we're here.
That's awesome.
It really made me happy.
Would that be reflected
in that video?
Or is it something that, you
know, it's like [INAUDIBLE]??
CHRIS BOEBEL: You
mean this video
that we're talking about now?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Is there a fine line?
[LAUGHTER]
How should we go about that?
CHRIS BOEBEL: I hope
there's not a fine line.
Certainly there shouldn't be
a fine line in what you do.
I mean, I can't tell you
that if you find somebody
who is the poster child
for whatever, IHTFP,
that it's going
to be no problem.
But the goal, the
whole point of this,
is to erase that fine
line, or blur it.
Because as I said, the very
simple way to do this project
would be for me, with
the help of the dean
of undergraduate
education or something,
to cast students
and profile them.
And I was resistant to
doing that because I thought
that there was a danger
that it could end up
being like a slicker,
contemporary version of what
we watched.
So, as I said, this
is an experiment
to try to do
something different.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Could I--
I'm sorry, it could be very
well because of how noisy
this room is.
So, basically,
your question is--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Are
there boundaries?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: We saw it was
very much a PR film from a very
top-down point of view.
It felt very contrived.
And we laughed at a
lot of it because we
thought it was amusing.
One of the questions
we found, then,
so if you want to get at this
question about MIT students,
how do you do it not in that--
not in a way that
it's not about PR,
but it's about trying to
capture something that's more--
in a way, we've had
so many discussions
about the real relation
and all this stuff.
I don't want to
use that language,
but how do you get
at something that's
far more open and evolving,
and it's not just a PR look?
So, that's one of the questions
that I have for all of you
then.
I know this exercise--
[INAUDIBLE] Some,
but not that much.
But in terms of actually going
about and shooting an interview
with the students, do
you have any ideas on how
you might go about
shooting or conducting
an interview in a way that
wouldn't have it be just PR,
but actually
getting [INAUDIBLE]??
And you'd be interested in that?
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
I mean, this partly
having asking you
folks to participate
is part of my answer,
my attempted answer,
at that very question
because how do you
get at those kinds of things?
Well, via MIT students
is the first part.
And the second part
is somewhat up to you.
AUDIENCE: I think that
rather than asking,
or in addition to asking
people about their experience
at MIT, because then, when
you create an original,
it's constructed
in a certain way.
And with a camera,
you tend to emphasize,
I guess, [INAUDIBLE]
posting those, especially
the first time that you
are in a short interview.
So it would be nice to see
people in their own space,
like walking around the lab.
So they're at cafes.
They go to the corridors,
the teams they work on.
Because I think just
walking in space
brings a different kind of
experiential dimension to it.
And the kind of
stories you tell--
they're still stories,
they're still narratives,
but they reflect more your
body experience around MIT.
So they might tell
much more things
than a [INAUDIBLE]
kind of a storyline.
So I was thinking about
doing something [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS BOEBEL: Absolutely.
I mean, if you look at, again,
the film that we looked at, I
talked about how I couldn't--
I was really taken by
the fact that it was
so much about infrastructure.
This is Walker Memorial.
This is the president's house.
But it's all
outside in, standing
on the outside looking in.
And what you're talking
about is inside out,
which is, again, exactly
what I'd love to get.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: And
I think that gets at--
which is why I'm
excited about it--
I think gets at that
issue of humanity.
Because you all are there.
You're connecting
with the students.
And the students are
the lifeblood of MIT.
So the question is, what
does the lifeblood of MIT
really look like?
And I think that's
the real question.
So I'm excited about
seeing what the answer is.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
I will say, too,
so Christopher runs the MSRP
program every summer, which
is a program for
undergrads to come to MIT
and do graduate research.
And we do video work
with them every summer.
And one of the things that
he does, which is wonderful,
is he gives cameras
to their students.
And these are not people
who are in a film class.
They're not people who
are trained at all.
But they get amazing stuff
that we could never get.
So clearly, you're going to
have a different perspective
just by virtue of who you are.
Plus, you're taking this
class, so hopefully--
it's only been a
couple of months,
but you've learned
something, right?
CHRISTOPHER JONES: [CHUCKLES]
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So we've talked
about lots of different
styles, or genres,
of documentary filmmaking
and different techniques.
So you can think about-- so
Katarina, what you were talking
about is kind of the
direct cinema style, where
you take a camera
and move around,
and you follow people
through their spaces,
whether it's labs or
dorms or whatever it is.
And then we were talking in the
last class about Errol Morris
and the interview style
where it's not really
about the interviewers'
questions.
It's about just
allowing somebody
to get into their own head
space and talk about what they
think is important to them.
It could be the focus
where the camera's
focusing on interactions.
So are there certain kinds
of student interactions
that you would want to convey?
So it would be
focusing on a student
but also, that student who's
very much in interaction
with others.
And if you wanted to focus on
that, what kind of interactions
would you want to focus on?
I'm trying to think of
other examples of some
of the other styles
that we've talked about.
We've still got more to go.
We're doing sensory
ethnography in the next class.
And the sensory ethnography
perspective on documentary
is really trying to get at the
sensory aspects of people's
day-to-day worlds.
So for example, if you
were working in a lab--
and for those of you
who saw the DV Lab
shorts from the last class,
the very first one by Christina
is a bit in that mode, where
she did this short film
about herself working in
a lab and the repetitive
nature of the lab work.
So she cut it in a
way where it was very
fun and enjoyable to watch.
But it was very much
about, OK, here's
the nature of what it's
like to work in a lab.
So is there a way
where you could
do a sensory
ethnographic perspective
on doing an interview with an
MIT student, where you would
kind of get at a student's
sensory experience of what it's
like to be at MIT
or to do whatever
it is that they're
interested, whatever they're
passionate about.
I'm trying to think of--
Chris, can you think
of other techniques?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, I mean,
there's the Jean Rouch thing.
An interview-based film could
be an Errol Morris-style film
or just a talking head film.
But think about Jean Rouch
and Chronicle of a Summer.
Basically, get people together.
Don't be afraid of being
involved, inserting yourself
in the film, and
get people talking.
Be intentionally
provocative or not
and get people
talking about whatever
it is that you're interested
in so that, in a sense,
they're almost
interviewing each other.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
And Jean Rouch, also,
think about the
technique in Jaguar,
where he got together with
Damouré and other people that
he [INAUDIBLE] made
that film with,
and he had them think out
a skit that would improvise
their lives.
So it was based
on improvisation,
of people improvising
and playing
with things that they wanted to
convey about their own lives.
I mean, is there a way
we can use that technique
to get at these questions?
I'm trying to think
of other ones--
Jean Rouch, direct cinema,
sensory ethnography,
the Errol Morris
[INAUDIBLE] style.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Vérité.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Now,
that's a question.
How would you do a vérité
take on an MIT student?
[CHUCKLES]
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Well, it would have
to be about MIT,
not MIT students.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Because I don't know.
You're at a bit
of a disadvantage,
just in terms of
what we've already
talked about in our class.
But we have been trying
to go through all
these different kinds
of documentary styles
and techniques
for different ways
that students might get at
various kinds of questions
about science and--
in terms of filming science
and engineering more broadly.
So the idea is to give lots
of different examples of how
you could do things
and then let students
take the tools that they
are most excited about
and do something really
creative with that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Cool, cool.
And I would just say--
and you already brought this
up, but you may have something
to say about this, too--
just thinking about who you
or, if it's a group of people,
what group you actually
talk to or profile is crucial.
And there are two things there.
One is don't just
interview your roommate
because they're your roommate,
and it's really easy.
But at the same time, you
also want to have access.
You want to have that
comfort level, potentially,
that we've talked about.
As you've all
experienced now, you
walk into a room of
strangers with a camera,
and it's very
different than walking
into a room of strangers
without a camera.
So there are two tensions there.
There's one, filming
what you know,
filming people that
already know you
and that you have a
rapport with, but two,
don't just do that
because it's easy.
So I guess what I'm hoping is
that you'll think about some
of the issues that
we've talked about today
and come up with a
subject that you have
a sense will get at
some of those things
in an unfiltered way--
I'm definitely not interested
in the Potemkin village
version of this--
but that also challenges you
as a filmmaker and as a person.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
That's also what
Dean Jones was talking
about in terms of getting
outside your comfort zone.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Yeah.
I would just add--
I would just
underscore that and say
that I would love to see you
all lean more towards the side
of those that you don't
have relationships--
I know access is always an issue
with any sort of these things.
But I think even in the process
of having to gain access
to some individual or group
that you haven't had access to
before, there's a lot
that you can learn from.
There's a deep
learning experience.
There's a book that was just
released, and you all came in--
no, we put it up on the web
when she came and spoke.
It's called The
Warmth of Other Suns.
And it's about the
Great Migration
of Blacks from the Southern
states to the Northern states.
And there was an individual,
Isabel Wilkerson,
who interviewed
over 1,200 people
in order to understand what
happened in this process.
It happened from the
beginning of World War I
until about 1970.
And over six million
African-Americans
moved from the
South to the North.
But in order to get
all these interviews,
she had to go through
so many different hoops
just to get access to people.
Because now, there are--
I don't remember exactly
what they call them,
but they're groups
or committees that
are in different
places in the North
that are based on where
people were from in the South.
So there's a Hattiesburg,
Mississippi club in Chicago.
And in order for
her to get access
to the Hattiesburg,
Mississippi club,
she had to talk to the
people that ran the club.
They had to have a meeting.
And they had to have a
vote on whether or not
they were going to give her
access to come into the club
and interact with them.
So you may have to go
through some hoops.
But even in the process of
going through the hoops,
I think you'll learn
a lot about yourself.
You'll learn a lot
about other individuals.
And I think it'll definitely
enrich the project.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And one last thing
I'll just say about Dean Jones,
his office is not
sponsoring this project.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Oh, no.
CHRIS BOEBEL: He's just here
because he's interested,
just to make it clear.
So this is not--
this is as unfiltered as
I can make it, hopefully.
But anyway, I know--
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Cool, thanks.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --you've
got a lot going on.
But thank you for coming.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: I'm excited.
Good stuff.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Any
questions for Christopher?
And we'll talk more
about the nitty-gritty
of this project later in class.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Cool.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Great,
well, thanks so much.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: All
right, thanks a lot.
CHRIS BOEBEL: OK, thanks a lot.
Don't forget the mic.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Cool.
Nice to meet you all.
Good luck with everything.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, thank you.
Talk to you soon.
CHRISTOPHER JONES:
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
Bye-bye.
CHRIS BOEBEL: OK,
well, why don't we
take just a short break.
And then when we
come back, we're
going to dive into some more
specific kinds of interview
techniques that you
can use just in terms
of thinking about how
to conduct an interview,
how to set things
up technically.
And then we can
also try to go over
some of the specifics
of this project.
Thanks.
We'll get started here.
And the first thing I want to do
is just run through some basic
considerations that you'll want
to be thinking about when you
tackle an
interview-based project--
and, again, interview-based
being interpreted
fairly broadly as anything from
a talking head-based project,
as, quote unquote, like
an Errol Morris film,
through something that's
a little more interactive,
something like we saw in
Chronicle of a Summer,
and anything in between.
So obviously, if you're
going to do anything
like that that's
interview-based,
audio becomes really,
really crucial.
And if you remember early on,
one of the things that I said
was that sometimes sound is
more important than picture.
And this is a situation in
which that becomes really true.
Obviously, if you can't hear
what the interviewee's saying
or if it's poorly recorded or
somehow, something goes wrong,
you don't really have
a lot to work with.
So I don't know-- have all of
you had a chance to play around
with the lavalier microphone,
or have you been mainly using
the boom at this point?
AUDIENCE: Just the boom.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Just the boom?
Has anybody messed
with a lavalier?
You?
OK.
So this is a situation
in which you may want
to consider using the lavalier.
And remember, again, that
the lavalier microphone
is omnidirectional,
which means that it's
really great at picking
up sound in any direction
from where it's located.
So in a relatively
quiet room, where
you can put it fairly close
to the person's mouth,
it's a great microphone
for an interview.
I'm wearing one right now.
Chris is wearing one right now.
It's very close to me.
This one, of
course, is wireless,
which is really great.
But we don't have wireless.
So thinking about
and making sure
that you are comfortable
with a lavalier microphone
might be something to consider.
Now, again, of course,
if you're doing something
where the person is
walking around in a space,
walking and talking, as
Katarina was talking about,
that isn't necessarily going
to work as well, primarily
because we have
wired microphones,
although you can try it.
I've done it myself.
It just means that the person
is tethered to the camera, which
can be awkward.
And again, if you're concerned
about impacting the scene
and making the person
feel uncomfortable,
that is something that would
make anyone feel uncomfortable.
Go ahead.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Maybe at the end,
if you guys are interested,
maybe we can have,
if there's time at
the end, have Dave
or you go over using the shotgun
mics on top of these cameras,
so exactly how you set them
up so you're ready to do that,
so if you want to
have better sound
but you want it just on
the camera without wires.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Now,
remember, the thing
about putting the
directional microphone
on top of the
camera, that actually
can be a pretty good interview
technique, as long as you can
stay fairly close to the
person and also as long
as you can stay
pointed at their mouth.
Because if they turn
their back on you
if you're walking
through a space,
their sound is going to
pretty much disappear.
Because this is so
directional that it's not
going to pick up anything
except what's bouncing back
at the microphone from whatever
surface is in front of them,
like a wall.
AUDIENCE: How close should
you be to the person?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Maybe
four or five feet.
Three feet would be great.
What is that, about four feet?
Probably about four feet is
as far as you want to be.
AUDIENCE: So say, technically,
if they're walking,
it would have to be
either on the side--
CHRIS BOEBEL: On the side or in
front, walking backwards, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
walking backwards.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
that would be great.
Walking backwards would
be the ideal way to do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
very difficult.
If you're planning on
following someone behind
and you want to get good
sound of them talking,
you're pretty much stuck with
either a lavalier microphone
or the boom.
Because of course, the boom can
go over the top of the person
or to the side.
So that's one
thing, just thinking
about how you're going
to mic the people.
And considering using
the lavalier if it
is, in fact, going to be
kind of a sit-down interview.
Second thing to think about
is, do you mic yourself?
Do you want your questions to
be part of what you record?
And obviously, that is
completely your choice.
There's a whole
school of filmmaking
where the interviewee--
interviewer, sorry-- is
cut out, and the questions
are not part of what's used.
And in that case, you
don't need to mic yourself.
Obviously, they can hear you.
There's no reason to
record what you're saying.
What that means,
though, is that you
need to get people to
answer in complete thoughts.
So anyway, so do
you mic yourself?
If you want to have
your questions be
part of the record, part of
what you're going to use,
you obviously do
need to mic yourself.
And you could do that
with the lavalier
and then use the
shotgun microphone
to record the person, for
instance, or vice versa.
You should put yourself
on a separate channel,
though, so you can put the
interviewee on channel 1
and you on channel
2, so that way you
can control them
separately in the edit,
and you have two inputs, which
we've gone over in class.
And obviously, we can
review that if you need to.
But to get back to the idea,
then, if you don't mic yourself
and you don't want to
include the questions,
you really need people
to say everything
that you need said in order
to tell whatever story it
is that you're telling.
So again, to go
back to this thing
that we were about to say with
Chris, if I am interviewing
Chris and I'm basically
trying to tell her life story
and I say, when were you
born, and she says 1965--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: '65.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --I
can't really use that.
Because all she said was 1965.
She has to say, I
was born in 1965.
AUDIENCE: So you
would ask questions
that imply an answer that's
a full sentence, like tell me
about your childhood.
And I should say,
I was born in--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Exactly.
And sometimes, I will just
be very upfront with people,
and I will say, try to
answer in complete thoughts.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So before
you start the interview
to alert them to that.
But people forget.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And I'll
explain, I'm not going to be--
no one's going to
hear my question,
so can you please answer
in complete thoughts?
And people are usually
pretty good about that.
One technique that
people also use,
which can be a little
dangerous, is they will say,
can you incorporate the
question in the answer?
So what happens
then is people say--
you ask, what are
MIT students like?
And they say, when
someone asks me,
what are MIT students
like, I usually say--
and so you can see
the difficulty.
On the one hand,
it's good because you
get the context for the answer.
But on the other hand,
it's kind of formulaic,
and it's a little weird.
So to go back to
the 1965 example,
if Chris said, when someone
asks me, when were you born,
I usually say 1965.
So it can get a little weird.
But it is one way to do it.
And it's kind of reliable
because people get it,
and they're able to do it.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But I
think Katarina was also right
on in terms of trying to think
of can you ask questions that
are general enough where,
kind of intuitively,
that kind of information
would be part of the story
that people tell.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
that's just a basic
of interviewing, asking
open-ended questions, not
do you like MIT?
Do you like MIT?
Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Or no.
So thinking about
what kind of questions
you need to get the kinds of
answers that you actually want.
And they tend to be
very, very open-ended.
Tell me about your
experience at MIT.
And then you can ask follow-ups.
And the follow-up is the real
art, I think, in interviewing.
Because you go in with
a list of questions
that you have in your mind that
you think are really important.
Maybe you've shared them with
the person you're interviewing.
Maybe you haven't.
And there are two schools
of thought on that.
If you share them, then they
may be much better prepared.
And that may be a good thing.
On the other hand, they may
be much better prepared,
and that may be a bad thing.
It just depends on
what you're going for.
If you want somebody to talk
in detail about their research
and to provide
statistics and all sorts
of specific
information, you really
want them to be prepared.
On the other hand, if you
want them to speak candidly
about their life, you may
not want them to be prepared,
not that you want to
put them on the spot,
but you want to
have them thinking
about it fresh
for the first time
as they're answering the
question, if that makes sense.
And of course, that also
depends on the person.
I mean, some people are really
obsessive about preparation
and get very nervous and
upset when you try to do that.
And some people are much
better spontaneously.
But to do a really
good interview that
isn't necessarily about specific
information or statistics, part
of your job as an interviewer is
to create an environment where
people can be spontaneous,
and they are comfortable.
And one of those
things may be not-- one
of the elements of creating that
environment may be not giving
them questions in advance.
So there isn't necessarily
a right or a wrong answer
to that.
But it really varies
and depends on-- go.
Were you going to say something?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Well, I
just had just a follow-up
when you were talking about
what kinds of questions to ask.
So Chris gave a really
good example-- tell me
about your experience at MIT.
And the good thing about
that is that it's open-ended.
But the other thing that's
good about that is it's
also specific.
Because one of
the things there's
a tendency, particularly
for those of us
trained as academics,
we often tend
to ask abstract questions,
where if you phrase it instead
of telling me about
your experience at MIT,
if it's instead,
well, we're trying
to capture what might be the
ideal typical MIT student,
and has there been a--
in this kind of abstracted way.
And then you ask an abstracted,
intellectual question.
Then people are
kind of like, uh,
how do you want me to respond?
It's not a good
interviewing technique.
And particularly people
trained in academics
have to be really
careful about this.
But so finding a question
that's both open-ended but also
very specific and grounded, like
tell me about your experience
at MIT, that's perfect.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And the
follow-up question,
I mentioned that the follow-up
question is really important--
or questions--
that's why.
Because if you say, tell me
about your experience at MIT
and they start
talking about things,
then you can take what they're
saying and, spontaneously
yourself, follow up on the
things that are interesting
and that start to key into
whatever your approach is.
And of course, you also
need to be prepared
to throw your approach
out the window
if it doesn't seem to
be the right way to go.
One thing that--
I might have mentioned this
before, at the beginning,
in the first class-- but
years ago, I saw an interview
with Errol Morris
where he talked
about interview techniques.
And he said somewhat
provocatively,
because he's provocative,
and facetiously,
that the main thing
in doing an interview
is not to listen to what the
people are saying but to appear
that you're listening.
And I think what he
meant by that was that
if you're listening too much,
if you're listening too hard--
because obviously,
you are listening--
there's a real desire
to direct the interview
along particular channels
that you have planned out
in advance.
So let's say you're doing
something about MIT students.
And the whole point
of it is to find out
what kind of cooking people
like, where they eat lunch.
And so all you're
interested in is finding out
where people eat lunch, and what
they eat lunch, how they do it,
how they organize it.
And people might be giving you
amazing material and amazing
gems of things on
other subjects,
but you're continually
thinking in your head,
you're calculating, yeah,
but what about lunch?
Tell me about lunch?
Come on, come on.
And they're laying
out their life story
and saying all
this amazing stuff.
And all you're focused
on with tunnel vision
is the questions that
you want answered.
And that is very,
very true, especially
when you're doing journalistic,
directed interviews.
There is a real tendency
to want to do that
and to very much, very
tightly, control and direct
the interview.
And what he's saying, I
think, in that comment
is throw that stuff
out the window
so that when some
kind of amazing thing
happens in the interview,
if you're not really
listening to it, then
it'll just happen,
and you won't try to force
it or jam it into the subject
that you had preordained.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: The
slightly less extreme version
of that would be an
anthro take on this,
where, as opposed to the,
OK, here's my questions
they haven't answered--
I'm only gotten to one, and they
haven't answered three, four,
and five, and, as Chris
is saying, you really
try to direct them-- but
for anthropologists who
do ethnographic field work, what
we get trained to do is that,
again, what's
interesting is what's
interesting to your
subjects, and so following
where they're going.
So in that case, it's actually
listening very intently
but listening with the
intent not because you
want to direct them
in a certain way
but listening with
the intent of trying
to understand, well, what is
it that's interesting to them?
And how can I
potentially ask questions
to help push it along in
that direction of what's
interesting to them?
So you're constantly--
again, it's not about,
as Chris is saying, it's
not about your preordained
conceptions when you're coming
in about what you should
be asking but what's
important to this person,
and how can I help unearth
what it is that they
find most interesting?
So it's questions towards
a different kind of end.
And it's always about being
in response and interacting
with what people themselves
feel to be important.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And the other
thing, I think, that is true,
whether you look at it
as don't listen at all
or listen very intently,
is that when you're really
on an agenda as an
interviewer, you
have a tendency to want to
knock things off the list.
So if the first question
is, tell me about your MIT
experience, they talk.
And you're, OK, next one is
about, where do you have lunch?
And you're, OK, OK, I gotta
get to the next question.
You have a tendency
to jump in as it
seems that they're finishing
with the next question.
But what I've found--
and I've done over
a hundred interviews
this year, so I do this a lot--
people have a tendency-- there's
kind of a rhythm of speech
where they finish and
then, if you wait a moment,
they'll continue.
And usually, when
they continue, it's
the deeper, kind of more
personal, more unexpected
answer.
Because there's
something about it.
There's a rhythm
of conversation.
I say something.
Chris says something.
Well, if that rhythm is
broken, and suddenly, it's
more on the person
who's speaking,
that can be the moment when
something else comes out.
So there's a
technical reason not
to jump, as well,
which is that you don't
want to overlap the audio.
You don't want their
audio and yours
to overlap because that can
cause a problem in editing,
particularly if you're trying
to cut your questions out.
But also, waiting a beat
just to see if they have
something else to say, is
often giving them permission
to say something else.
And that can be some of the
most interesting and unexpected
stuff.
So again, not really trying to
forcibly direct the interview--
although, of course,
you are directing it--
is really important.
Just a couple of other things.
So we were talking--
I think I said that,
probably, job number
one as an interviewer is to
make people feel comfortable
and to make them feel like
they have permission to speak
and to say things that
are natural and possibly
unexpected.
One really good
way of doing that
is thinking very
carefully about how you're
going to start the interview.
Especially for people who
aren't comfortable with being
on camera, aren't used
to being on camera,
there's a real tendency,
particularly when
you're working on
a bigger production
with a lot of equipment,
that everything
gets focused on the equipment.
So the camera gets set up.
If you have lights,
you're setting up
the lights, the audio.
The poor person who you're going
to interview is sitting there,
and they're a guinea
pig for the lights,
and you're adjusting everything.
Maybe you're slapping
makeup on them.
You're putting a
microphone on them.
You're asking them
to do an audio test,
you know-- what's the level?
Like, 1, 2, 1, 2.
Can you say that again?
Speak a little louder.
And they get very
uncomfortable, of course,
because it's this big deal.
But if you can do that more
unobtrusively-- and obviously,
one of the nice things is
we hardly have any equipment
in this class compared
to the load like that--
so doing it unobtrusively
is very, very helpful
to setting the tone for
a more natural interview.
And then the other thing
is how you start it.
If all of that complicated
setup and running
around leads up to,
OK, are we ready?
Are we ready?
Everyone rolling?
All right, begin.
Be natural.
Go, now.
That is obviously going to put
a lot of people on the spot
and make them very
uncomfortable.
On the other hand--
and this is another reason
for working in teams,
even if you don't
have a lot of stuff--
if one person is doing
all of the technical setup
and framing the shot and
setting up the camera
and working with audio
and the other person who's
going to be doing the interview
is chatting with the person
the whole time, and then if the
camera just naturally starts
rolling and you continue your
conversation, then suddenly,
it's become an interview
without any kind of go.
Now you're on.
Now we started.
And that can be
really, really helpful,
as I said, especially for
people that are not really used
to being on camera.
Because you think about it.
We've had the experience of
being filmed in this class
off and on over the
last couple of months.
And how different is it
when the cameras aren't here
or when we forget that
the cameras are here?
So the point is that you want to
erase the camera from the room
as much as possible.
And the way to do that, as Chris
has said a couple of times,
have a human subject for
them to focus their attention
on while the technical
stuff is happening.
And that isn't so maximized.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Just-- unless
your intent is to do something
Jean Rouchian, where the
idea, then, in that case--
because that could
be another way
to do it, then,
where you want it
to be about the interaction
with the camera,
but it's meant to be a dialogue,
a discussion back and forth.
And then you've got
a whole other way
of thinking about the interview.
But that could be another way
to do it, where it's like, OK,
it's a conversation between
the camera and this person.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yep.
So just want to throw out a few
video considerations, as well.
We've been talking a lot about
audio and interview techniques.
Again, remember that doing an
interview-based film, that's
very broadly conceived.
Something that is Errol
Morris-like, or what
we think of as a conventional
talking head interview,
is one option.
And that generally involves
having a camera on a tripod
and having the person
either looking into the lens
or at an interviewer
sitting next to the camera,
just off access from the lens.
And that's a perfectly
great way to do things.
But it's not the only
way to do things.
You talked about having
people walking through a space
and talking, some kind of
environmental interview,
a hand-held interview where the
camera is actually mobile, even
if the person's not mobile.
All of those are other options.
And they're all
perfectly valid choices.
You just need to
think about what
is the option that
communicates what
you're hoping to communicate?
Is this a controlled setting?
Is it an uncontrolled setting?
Do you want some fluidity?
Do you want them
to be interacting
with their environment?
Or are you going to
get the interaction
with the environment separately?
Are you going to interview
them in a more controlled space
and then film them
doing the stuff
that they're talking about?
And I'll talk about
that in a minute.
So that's one thing, just
thinking about the techniques
that you're going to
use in the interview
to convey a feeling
that you want to convey.
If you are doing something
that is a tripod-based, kind
of standard, video
interview, you
want to think about the
framing of the people.
We talked about framing,
if you remember,
this idea that the really
powerful parts of the frame
are the corners, where the
frame is divided into thirds.
Did a bad job there.
But these are very
powerful parts of the frame
because our eyes tend to
be drawn to those points.
So the standard way
of framing someone--
and when I say standard, I mean
that sounds kind of pejorative,
like, oh, well, we don't want to
be standard-- but this actually
it works really well.
Framing somebody looking this
way on this side of the frame
so that their eye is more
or less in that point
or, alternatively, framing
somebody looking that way,
so their eye, one of their
eyes, is at that point.
And that's just a really
good, appealing way
of framing people.
And then remembering, also--
does this go down?--
if you have somebody
framed like that,
what's the relationship
between the person's face
and the background?
The last thing you want
is for the person's face
to blend into the background.
And there are a number of
ways that you can avoid that.
There's lighting, if you
have light, obviously.
You don't want the
background to be
much brighter than the
person's face, for example.
What you really want is for the
background to fade in some way
so that the face
kind of jumps out.
And that's why, for instance,
we've talked about long lenses
being very good, appealing
ways of shooting people,
particularly in
interview situations.
What that does is it allows
you to have the face be
in very sharp focus
and the background
to be soft and out of focus.
And that, again, is a way
of having the face jump out.
So focus, of course,
is critical--
always critical but
particularly critical
when you're shooting people.
What you want to do
is zoom in all the way
to the person's face-- to their
eye because you always want
to focus to the eye--
focus very carefully.
And then you can zoom out
to whatever frame you want.
Also, thinking about
varying the frame.
This is kind of a
medium-close shot.
But you could just
as easily film people
in a wider shot,
a very wide shot.
Or you could do the Frontline,
60 Minutes thing and film
people in a very close shot.
Or you could do all of them.
You could move the camera
or zoom in and out.
What were you going?
AUDIENCE: I have a
technical question.
So like in Gates of
Heaven, when Errol Morris
has those amazing--
I know you weren't
rewatching it,
but you've seen it
a zillion times--
but when he does those
amazing portraits and then
in the background
you have the cacti
or whatever it is, but the
faces are totally clear,
but the background
is also totally--
pops.
So how exactly did he
shoot that in order
to get that [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Because that's--
again, he's not doing a
lot of the standard things
in that film.
So yeah, the backgrounds
aren't out of focus.
What he's doing is
carefully orchestrating
what is in the background so
that it's completely vivid
but also not completely
fighting the face.
So you can do it with
art direction, as well.
There is something back
here that is really vivid
and kind of dynamic, but
it's not competing-- just
by the nature of
the framing, it's
not competing--
with the foreground.
So art direction is
another way to do this.
One thing to just note
about art direction--
this is just a personal
thing of mine--
there is such a thing
as being too on the nose
with art direction.
And what I mean is
let's say you're
doing something on lab safety.
And you interview
somebody, and there's
a sign in the background
that says, like, radiation.
And it's completely
sharp and in focus.
And this person is
talking about radiation.
That's kind of on the nose.
Now, it might work if this
is a radiation symbol,
and it's completely soft
and not distracting.
But there's something about text
and establishing your subjects
in a very, very
obvious and overt way
that can get a
little weird for me.
And there are also
things in the background
that can be distracting,
unintentionally distracting.
That's always something
to consider, as well.
The classic is--
I don't know if
you saw this, but I
think it was last year
or the year before--
Sarah Palin gave an
interview at Thanksgiving
when she was still
governor of Alaska.
And they were slaughtering
turkeys behind her.
And there's this completely
sharp-focused shot
of this guy slaughtering
turkeys and staring at her.
And she's talking about
Thanksgiving and the beauty
of the holiday and so on.
And it was just hilarious.
And it was hilarious
because there
was this utterly distracting
and bizarre event happening
behind her that the cameraperson
didn't really think about.
Or you can do that for comic--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Or did
and did it intentionally.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
yeah, good question.
I don't know.
But and obviously, you
can do that intentionally.
You can have something going on
in the background that comments
on the foreground intentionally,
either comically--
it often ends up being comic--
or not.
So anyway, these are
all things to think
about when you're setting up a,
quote unquote, "talking head"
interview.
The other thing, which
we've talked a little bit
about in class, are
lighting techniques.
Obviously, we don't have lights.
But that doesn't mean
that you can't use light
or shouldn't use
light to do better
jobs with your interviews.
Well, Max can tell you you can
find lights that can be used.
He did that a couple of times,
basically using desk lights,
clip lights, things like that.
And that's one option.
The big thing to
think about there
is not making things
too harsh, not
making your shadows really
harsh or creating weird lighting
effects on the people, unless
you're doing it intentionally.
But if you're doing natural
light, thinking about--
we've talked about it before
but just to reiterate--
thinking about where
the light sources are
and how that affects the
person you're filming.
So again, in this room, if I was
getting interviewed in the room
by Andrew, which I am,
if I stood in front
of the window like
this, especially
if the blinds were up,
I suddenly get backlit.
And suddenly, my face is not
bright in the frame at all
compared to the background.
But if I come over
here and I stand under,
or I'm positioned
under, this light so
that suddenly, I'm in
a pretty good spot,
my face is brighter than the
background, which is the board.
So you can position
people in various ways
to take advantage of that.
And harsh lighting makes
people look one way.
Softer lighting-- one
of the nice things
about this kind of material
is that it breaks up light
really nicely.
So this is a very
nice, soft light that
makes people look really nice.
So one thing you could
do, which we can't really
demonstrate with
this camera, is I
could be interviewed this
way with window light on me.
And the camera could
be facing here.
So now I have this really nice,
soft light source lighting me.
And it would actually be a
really, potentially, very
nice way of doing it.
So don't be afraid
to position people
and to use the
environment around you
to get what you want.
And of course, being
outside, the same thing.
You could film
somebody outside at
sunset with the sun low
in the sky behind them,
and suddenly
they're silhouetted.
Or you could turn them
around, and then you
have this sort of
golden light on them.
And those are choices
that you can make.
So anyway, thoughts or questions
about this at this point?
OK.
One other thing that I
wanted to do and then maybe,
in the last 15 or 20
minutes, we can just
go over if there are just
basic technical questions
about the camera or sound
that people want to reiterate.
I wanted to revisit
this idea of I
guess is the word illustrating
interviews, the question of,
OK, so you've done an interview.
How do you actually
make it come alive?
And one way to do it, of
course, is to do something,
as Katarina was talking about.
Just interview somebody in situ.
Have them walking around,
describing what they do.
And have it be very
fluid and very mobile.
The other way to
do it, of course,
is to interview them
and then go out and do
what Errol Morris does--
get material that reinforces
or reiterates or explicates
what they're talking about.
So if somebody is talking about
the biolab that they work in,
you do a half-hour interview
with them about the biolab.
And then you go to
the lab, and you
shoot them working, doing the
things that they were talking
about, illustrating the
important things that were
discussed in the interview.
And that's a great way--
that's a great
sequence to do it in.
Do an interview first.
And then go and
think about what you
need in order to tell the story
that came out in the interview.
The nice thing about that
is that it doesn't kind of
prejudice the interview
so that you can be very
exploratory in the interview.
And then you can go
and get exactly what
you need to tell the story.
The other way to
do it, of course,
is to film the of vérité
stuff, the mobile stuff,
first and then do interviews
that connect the dots
to the mobile stuff.
And I wanted to
show a short film
that I worked on a few years
ago, which is completely
shifting gears in
terms of genre.
It's a mockumentary.
It's a very low-budget
mockumentary,
a fake documentary
that I worked on.
And it stars Ed Helms.
And it was done on a very, very
low budget very, very quickly.
And because it was all
completely improvised,
we did the opposite.
We basically filmed all of the--
and I'm not going to tell
you too much about it--
but we filmed all the
walking around first,
and then we did the
interview second.
Because since he's a really
amazing improv actor,
he was able to
connect all the dots.
But I'm just going
to show it quickly.
Then we can talk about it.
And it's a profile.
It's not an MIT student,
but it is a profile.
I just wanted to show
that, first of all,
because it was done not with
too much more time and resources
than we have here.
We shot it really, really
quickly in Brooklyn one day,
one Sunday afternoon.
And it was the opposite of what
we were just talking about.
We went out with Ed and just--
after he was done with
his makeup, which took
about as long as the shooting--
we just wandered
around Brooklyn.
And we knew that we had
a couple of scenarios,
like he was going to
go play basketball
and that he would be
stood up on a date.
But we didn't really know
what else we were going to do.
And then we went back
and did an interview,
which connected all the dots.
And because he's an improv
actor and really good at it,
he was able to tie it
all together for us.
So anyway, there's just
that whole question of,
how do you tell a story?
What's the story
you're going to tell?
This was a situation
where, again,
other than the basic scenarios
and the fact that he was
a zombie and that it was going
to be about the daily life
struggles of a zombie done in
this kind of particular way,
we didn't really have a story.
So I guess the
last couple things.
Just to go over again
next week, you've
all done the direct
cinema exercise.
The idea now is to do an
interview-based exercise,
as we've been discussing.
And next week, if one
person in each team
could edit one or
the other, a version.
Obviously, it doesn't have
to be the be-all end-all.
But as completely as you
can, put together something--
it doesn't have to be more
than a few minutes long--
that is a best guess
at what you were
trying to do with
each of the exercises.
So does that make sense?
Questions about that?
All right.
So then, just the last thing.
I wanted to leave
enough time to deal
with specific technical
questions that
may have come up, either about
camera or sound recording.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
One other thing--
unless somebody
had something else
they wanted to say-- but
you had asked earlier
about moving doing handheld
and moving with somebody.
And then the question's
then about how
do you get, if you've got
the shotgun mic on top,
how do you keep getting sound?
And Chris was talking
about walking backwards.
So just one follow-up
technical thing on that.
It's a really good
technique to learn
how to do to walk backwards.
I would practice first.
[LAUGHS] And you
should be particularly
careful with your ankle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] part
of my physical therapy.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
also, never do it
unassisted, at least if
there's any kind of question
about the terrain or
bumping into something.
No, seriously, you
can fall down stairs.
You can break
cameras, break your--
sorry-- break something on you.
You just don't want to do it.
Usually, what we do when
we're walking backwards is--
again, you're working
in teams of two--
so here.
If Chris is walking backwards
with the camera, I'm here,
and I'm doing this,
like OK, step,
step, step, so moving
things out of the way,
making sure that-- telling
her if there's something
that she's going to bump into
or tapping her to move this way.
And that's just something
you really want to Do.
Because again, you get so
involved in the shooting,
you get so involved in
the shot you're taking,
that even if you know
very well that there's
a table of glassware behind
you, you're almost guaranteed
to run into it.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: We have
some really funny footage.
[LAUGHS]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Oh,
is this the tree?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
We were shooting in East
Africa on this little island
where I had done my fieldwork.
And Chris was doing-- we
were walking up a path,
and there were all
these coconut trees.
And so Chris was shooting
handheld, walking backwards.
And we have the sound
of like, oo-ahh,
when he hits the coconut
tree and goes splat.
So we actually spent a
lot of time maneuvering
the coconut trees with
that particular one.
So it's a really great
technique to have.
And it really frees you up to be
able to do stuff more handheld,
which can be really fun.
Again, it's all about
what you want to capture.
Do you want to do the
Errol Morris-type thing?
Do you want to do the movement?
But if you do want to be able
to do stuff that's more mobile,
learning those
kinds of techniques,
and so just practicing
them, maybe,
with having a friend
spot you, is a good idea.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And thinking
about how the shot changes.
Again, the little thing
we just watched, actually,
is a good example of this.
So stand up again.
So basically, I walked
all over Park Slope
with Ed and Nick
and the sound guy.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Oh, so
when you were on the street?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah.
So I walked backwards a lot.
And Nick was--
Nick Poppy, the
director-- was guiding me.
But then I would come around to
the side and walk next to Ed,
or I would walk behind him.
He would do his thing where
he would interact with people,
and I would find another angle.
And Nick would know
to step out of the way
and just make sure he
wasn't in the shot.
And then if I started
walking backwards again,
he would run in and
start guiding again.
So it's just staying very
fluid and just remembering
that you can change shots.
You can change from one kind of
shot to another kind of shot.
You can film feet.
You can film cutaways.
You can shoot film
point of view.
So another thing
that you might do
is, if you're walking
backwards, filming
this person walking
through the environment,
you can flip around.
And all of a sudden,
you're shooting the point
of view of that person.
So you can shoot what's
happening on the street, what's
ahead, then rotate back,
film here, go behind,
go over the shoulder of
the person, film a profile.
And the main thing
there, again, is
to think about holding
the shots long enough so
that there actually is
something there to use.
If you're continually
moving and changing,
you end up with nothing.
It's kind of the equivalent
of hosing down the room.
But definitely
don't lock yourself
into one kind of angle.
Try to be aware of
what's interesting
and what's going on.
And try to change
angles to do that.
And that was one of
the things, also,
that I wanted to show that
was fun about that piece.
Even though it obviously
is a mockumentary,
it was very much unscripted.
Other than the fact that
we knew we had permission
from that restaurant to
film in the restaurant
at a particular time of day, we
didn't really have an agenda.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So
that, in some ways,
is very similar to the
Jean Rouch technique,
say, in Jaguar, where
you get together,
and you decide, OK, here
are certain parameters.
There's a couple of
things we want to do.
And then the rest of it
is improv along the way.
In the last five
minutes, since people
might want the
flexibility to do that,
should we get out a shotgun mic?
Do you want to show how to
put them onto the camera?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah.
Is that something that
people are interested in--
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Knowing how to do?
CHRIS BOEBEL:
--finding out about?
Because that is a great
intermediary technique.
And it's definitely
better than the mic
that comes with the camera.
So anyway, this mic fits
into the same place.
But one thing you'll notice
right away when you try it
is that it's too loose.
So what we usually do--
we don't have it here--
but we have that blue paper
tape, the painter's tape,
that you can get a roll of.
And you can wrap
it around the mic.
The nice thing about
that painter's tape
is that it comes
off very easily.
I wouldn't use masking
tape or scotch tape or tape
that is hard to peel off.
But that blue
painter's tape, you
can wrap it around and build up
the thickness of the microphone
so that it actually does fit
relatively snugly in here.
Because it's close.
It's just a little bit off.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And there's
painter tape in DV Lab
that you can use if you want.
CHRIS BOEBEL: What's that?
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
I'm just telling
them there's painter's tape
in DV Lab that they can use.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
So if you want to do this, just
take a roll of painter's tape
when you check out
your equipment.
CREW: There's tons of
it, too, by the extension
back there with just the
tape if you guys need some.
CHRIS BOEBEL: We
got a lot, yeah.
The other issue that you're
going to run into, however--
and this is a little trickier--
is that on a wide angle,
this sags into the frame.
So especially, even
if it's built up
and it's like that,
on the widest angle,
this is going to
be in the frame.
And you're going
to need to think
of a way to deal with that.
One thing that I've done,
which has a slight downside,
is you can take another
piece of tape and angle
this up just a little bit.
Angling it up that
much is enough to have
it clear the frame.
But of course, now you're
pointing up a little bit.
So it's you're a
little bit off axis,
unless you're filming Dave,
in which case, it's perfect.
So that's one thing.
Other people did other things.
Somebody, I think, managed
to actually secure it
to the top of the
mount, like that.
You just need to be
sure that it's secure.
Because I don't want it,
obviously, to fall off.
And the other thing is it needs
to be pretty snugly attached.
Because if it does
this a lot, you're
going to get sound problems.
You're going to get
a lot of interference
with the microphone.
Because remember, it's
just like the boom.
Handling noise-- the
mic shaking around,
bumping into things,
hand on the boom
or hand on the mic-- all of
that comes out as interference.
So anyway, so that
is a potential way
to do it if you can do it
securely with the tape.
And that, again, is just enough
to get it out of the frame.
And that way, it's
still pointing forward.
So that actually is
another pretty good option.
I don't know if we've ever tried
this or if it's even doable.
CREW: Just cutting
into the foam itself.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, I don't
want them to cut the foam.
CREW: No, I meant use
it like this could--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, I was
just going to do that, yeah.
I don't know if that
actually fits, though.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Could you tape over--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah,
another option, maybe,
which I haven't tried, would
be to do something like that.
Bring it back just far enough.
And then you can't close that.
CREW: Maybe use some of the
tape to tighten it a little bit
and restrict it.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
Or the other thing you could
do is push the foam forward
and bring it back.
The only thing here, you don't
want to cover the pickups.
Remember, these slots
on the sides of the mic
actually are audio pickups.
So you don't want to have
those in the mount like that.
So you could go back right
to that point, like that.
But anything further
back is going
to become a problem for you.
But anyway, so there is a
bit of a technical challenge.
There are a couple of
ways of getting around it.
But it is a way for you to
avoid that issue of the boom
being so intrusive.
It's more limited,
though, than the boom.
Because although
you're getting a nice--
so from here, I could do get
pretty decent audio of Dave.
Back here, not so much.
I mean, it'll be better
than the camera mic,
but it's not going
to be fantastic.
And of course, I also
can't come over the top.
I don't have any reach.
So with the boom, I can be
back here, filming you two.
And then the boom
person can be like this.
But of course, you two
may be very ill at ease
with this thing
hanging over your head.
So it's a trade-off.
CREW: The benefit of doing
the 45 degree angle from above
is that you don't
get the ambient noise
behind the person--
well, not as much of it, anyway.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
again, remember, these
are very directional.
So if I'm filming
Dave on a loading dock
and there's a truck
idling behind him,
I'm going to pick up the
truck really, really well.
If I'm coming in like this,
I'm not, really, so much.
Because the pattern is down.
But I'm still going
to hear his sound.
So that's another consideration.
But this is something that we've
done very successfully that's
less obtrusive.
And it's definitely worth
knowing and thinking about.
And it's a good technique for
certain kinds of situations.